and we all have personal opinions  but it doesn't mean that just because  you're with an older woman  that  um they are taking advantage of you and  you're just having fun how about  consider that somebody a little bit  older than you might actually be  interested in you it's not always for  fun I mean you can ask that to me  personally if I'm in getting involved  with someone  I'm not interested in fun you know I've  got  personal views self-respect I don't need  to go around dropping my pants like all  these other girls that I don't need to  do all that so it doesn't matter who I  date  I'm interested in something  proper I think the word is proper  something proper and not to play around  so obviously I'm not going to date you  sort of sorry